for the tampa bay rays here tonight it's
going to be left-hander rich hill making
his 17th start of the season six and
three on the record 3.70
earned run average
and there is a cut in the miss he gets
hernandez on the curveball i'll tell you
what that was a dandy too because he
started that right out over the heart of
the plate swinging and a miss
he struck him out again at a 70 mile an
hour curveball back-to-back case to
start the ball game and rich hill is way
ahead of his pace logan allen will be
the uh indian starting pitcher tonight
one and five he's coming off a start
against detroit where he went three in
the third innings gave up three hits and
three runs manuel marco starts the night
hitting 241 with nine home runs ground
ball and there's a base hit
to the left of cesar hernandez and into
right randy or rosarenda
chops it to third what a play by jose
ramirez and the indians are able to turn
the double play
they go 5-4-3 around the horn it was
very close well let's take a look nice
play by jose to get rid of it quickly
over to hernandez as they turn it he is
gonna be
well it's tough to tell but it looks
outside just barely big fan male reyes
will lead off inning number two for
cleveland
there's a wave and a miss
he had
reyes reaching out in front of the
breaking ball here's the break that ball
starts off the plate stays off the plate
and he still gets the swing eddie
rosario
and the chopper toward the middle
challenged by bronco he was back a
little bit realized he was gonna have to
come and get that thing with that big
hop and he managed to get that play to
first take a look at eddie coming out of
the box
on that last he just hit it down into
the ground it didn't look like anything
was hurting him
well there's a little yeah grimace right
there on the face yep harold ramirez
with two down and the base is empty now
the o2 pitch from the lefty is swung out
and missed strike three and he has
struck out a pair in each of the first
two innings well eddie rosario out of
the game i mentioned coming out of the
box he did not get down the line at all
and so he's out of the game oscar
mercado takes over and left bradley
zimmer goes into center field rays find
the hole again their second hit of the
night with one on and one out here's
jimon choy
adds a shot into right romero is going
back
he'll play him as it hops the wall
on his way to third diaz linares will
stop him it's a double for joy and the
rains have been in second and third
single double walk the bases are loaded
for brandon lau first time he's batted
in the eighth spot this year and lau
swings and connects
deep to right and that one is out of
here
grand slam for loud
with one swing of the bat the raves lead
by four
palau
has hit five home runs off lefties he
only has 10 hits against left-handed
pitching but five are home runs and for
all the home runs he's hit in the big
leagues that is his first slam the
indians have something going now lead
off base runner at second base and jose
ramirez will step in here's the pitch
breaking ball low and in and ramirez
checked his swing or did it hit him he
checked his swing and it did hit him the
home plate umpire said hit by pitch
right in the back foot first and second
for fran mill reyes and reyes swings
lines it to left that will get down for
a base hit headed for third being waved
around is rosario he will score and the
indians are on the board sampa bay four
the tribe one still nobody out and
bradley zimmer will be the batter for
the tribe
and a swing again
well breaking ball breaking ball
breaking ball two down in the inning
bobby bradley the batter up and in and
it hit him bradley hit by a pitch to
load him up for roberto perez and that's
it here comes kevin cash hill's knight
is done in the fourth he is pulled from
this game with a three run lead two outs
but the bases are loaded so the rays
will go to right-hander drew rasmussen
line drive caught it first by joy and
the race fortunate the g-mon choi lined
up right where he needed to be the
indians leave three we head to the
bottom half of the fourth inning logan
allen back out
there that balls hammered right into the
glove of jose ramirez who made a leaping
stab for out number one
robbing mike zanino of at least a hit if
not a double runners on the corners for
the raise emanuel
and he will not face logan allen justin
garza's coming on first pitch lined
towards right moving to his left as
harold ramirez slides and makes the
catch near the foul line tosses into
second as loud tags and scores and the
rays get the run back it's 5-1 raise
here in the forward that ball gets by
him then two are going to score he makes
a nice sliding catch and now randy arose
arena will step in drives one high and
deep to right this one's way back there
ramirez at the wall leaps and he made
the catch as he slammed into the fence
what a stretch of two hitters
defensively for harold ramirez in right
and now the indians have runners in
second and third nobody out ahmed
rosario of the batter
and he chops the breaking ball to third
only play first they get the out there
one down mercado scoring and it's now
five to two jose ramirez will step to
and
the
line drive single into right field
coming around third cesar hernandez will
score jose ramirez delivers yet again
rbi number 51 on the year and the
indians climbing right back in and it's
now five to three grand male reyes still
just won out one swing away from tying
this game up
runner goes to that smoke deep center
keermar back he won't make the play was
that over the fence that's a home run
yes indeed
brad mill reyes
the franimo has tied the game
with a two-run blast to center making it
a four-run fifth for cleveland oh mama
yeah right man in the right spot we've
got a tie ball game so the early hook by
kevin cash going to the bullpen does not
pay off two up two down yandy diaz the
batter swung on line drive center field
moving over diving and making the
catches bradley zimmer
there's vintage zimmer laying out
hauling it in and the go ahead run for
the indians is now 90 feet away now the
infield is drawn in swinging a little
bloop job into shallow center franco
can't get their base hit indians take
the lead a bloop single to center by
cesar hernandez second and third two
outs fran mill reyes the batter swung on
hit a ton to deep right center field
kirmeyer racing back at the wall it's
off the wall that is going to score
hernandez and ramirez and for the big
man it's a five rbi night fran mia reyes
with a two-run double and a rocket off
the wall in right center right at the
382 mark and the indians have now taken
a three-run lead and the raves will have
two men on and the potential tying run
coming to the play and one more goal
coming up
and a little looping lighter base
heading to right
they're going to send short throw not in
time and the rey is going to run back
it's 8-6 joy scores from second kierbyer
stops at second
on that soft lighter into right driving
in
the second run of the night by margaux
and here is yandy diaz two out nobody on
in the seventh inning eight six
cleveland that's a shot into right field
toward the corner romero is looking up
good
bye
home run opposite field for yondi diaz
and it's a one-run ball again the bottom
of the ninth next and now it's up to
emanuel clausse to hold an eight to
seven lead
arose
and franco rounded back off a class a
dribbles out toward the second baseman
hernandez throw to first not in time
close play and right now they say margot
is safe manuel looks a little bit a
little banged up
some could uh with the leg
that is a close play and margot just
given it all that he's got walking very
very gingerly as he makes his way back
into the first base dugout so brett
phillips is going to come out and run so
the first two men reach against evanual
class a and now can the rays continue
the rally here wander franco will be the
hitter
and a big chant in into that center
field a big hop out there that's going
to allow phillips to score the rose
arena goes to third and the second goes
bronco and this game is tied 8-8 wander
franco comes here the intentional walk
sends meadows to first
and it is yandi diaz who's two for four
tonight including a home run in the
seventh
and a chopper to the right side throw to
the plate it's wide ray's winning
rosarian scores the rays with two in the
ninth
win this one nine to eight and boy what
a ball game this one turned out to be